ne l'appelez plus RC mais ligne V V
comme Versailles V peut-être aussi pour
davantage de viabilité car cette ligne
qui remplace le tronçon du rerc entre
Versailles chantier et Massip palzau se
transforme en Naette autonome et
indépendante du reste du réseau un
problème qui survient à Pontoise ou
ettemple n'aura en principe plus
d'incidence sur le trafic des trains
dans la vallée de la Bièvre une des
lignes les plus fiables d'Île-de-France
elle sera cadencée toutes les 15 minutes
et elle permettra de relier donc
Versailles à Massie à travers la vallée
de la Bièvre c'est une ligne qui se veut
un peu différente des lignes du
quotidien parce que c'est une ligne dans
laquelle on pourra mettre son vélo à
toute heure du jour et c'est une ligne
sur laquelle on va découvrir tout le
patrimoine de l'Île-de-France c'est
aussi une ligne qui a une vocation
touristique pour que on puisse aller se
promener à vélo ou à pied dans les
merveilles de la vallée de la Bièvre une
modification donc plutôt qu'un
prolongement du tramois T12 un temps
évoqué qui devrait améliorer le
quotidien des usagers 11 trains
supplémentaires par jour soit un toutes
les 15 minutes en heure de pointe la
ligne V relie Versailles à massipalés en
20 minutes et pour nous si vouz la
régularité est très importante parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens ici qui
chaque jour prennent ce train c'est une
ville importante qui est Versailles une
ville importante qui est Massie et entre
des villes très agréables à vivre et
donc ici c'est à la fois un agrément de
vivre parce que c'est vrai que c'est une
zone verte que l'on met en valeur on a
souligné l'Ance vélo mais c'est aussi
une zone très essentielle au point de
vue du développement économique pour la
région î-de-fance sur l'aspect visuel
peu ou pas de changement les trains
restent les mêmes avec une mise en
valeur à l'intérieur du patrimoine bâti
et naturel de la vallée de la Bièvre
l'ancienne signalétique du RC sera elle
changée progressivement pendant un an
les usagers n'ont presque rien remarqué
est-ce que vous saviez que du coup le RC
allait devenir le RV pas du tout c'est
une belle découverte c'est vraiment
compliqué de faire du du banlieu à
banlieu bah dans en en banlieu et donc
oui s'il y a des trains qui sont
beaucoup plus présents et et qui
fonctionnent et qui sont fiables surtout
bah c'est c'est super ça va changer
radicalement la la fréquence des trains
donc ça ça sera parfait pour les usagers
par contre je regrette qu'il y ait plus
d'agent en gare sur la ligne de RORC et
des fois ça peut poser certains
problèmes la ligne V dessert
actuellement SEP gares et bientôt une 8e
une nouvelle station sera prochainement
créée dans le C du pileux à Massy